[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Howdy.
My name's Dustin Kirkland.
I want to say I
genuinely appreciate
each and every one
of you for being here
while Kelsey Hightower's giving
a keynote in Moscone South.
So it means quite a bit to
me, each and every person
who showed up here
to listen to this.
Learn a bit about how Google
is approaching hybrid cloud
computing and maybe see
some demos at the end.
Now, I do want to apologize
a little bit for this title
for being about as vague
as you can possibly be
in the title of a presentation.
And that was actually sort
of the fault of the fact
that we were releasing
GKE On-Prem as sort
of a big reveal, a big surprise,
in the keynotes on Tuesday
morning.
So this is the title
that I really wanted
to have for this presentation.
And this is really what
we're going to talk about.
We're going to talk about how
hybrid cloud solutions actually
apply to enterprise IT.
And all that is framed now,
now that we can talk openly,
about what GKE Google
Kubernetes Engine On-Prem--
on-prem, in the data
center, in the enterprise--
actually means.
So I'm Dustin Kirkland.
I joined Google about three
months ago as a product manager
on the Kubernetes team.
I've been around Kubernetes
for a couple of years now.
I've been around Open
Source for almost 20 years,
having started at IBM
working with big enterprises.
I spent the last 10 years in
my career working on Ubuntu,
developing and building Ubuntu
as a cloud operating system.
And have really shifted
gears at this point
to bring Kubernetes
technology into the enterprise
and doing that
with Google Cloud.
So the obligatory
safe harbor slide.
I think this goes
without saying,
but this is Google Next.
The conference is
literally called Next.
This is what we're doing next.
This is a peek at
where our roadmaps are
going for our products,
where our solutions are
headed for customers.
I've spent every
minute of this week
not in a presentation
with customers.
And that's been
dozens of customers
who have teamed up with me
and my fellow product managers
to help drive those
products in the direction
that enterprises need
and actually want.
So what you're
going to see here is
a look at where we're
taking GKE On-Prem,
and safe harbor guarantees
about how things might
change and evolve over time.
This is a good slide to take
a picture of, definitely.
All right, so point number one--
bringing Google Cloud
technology on prem
is an absolute game
changer for IT.
This was the initial premise
for this presentation.
Not premises, which is
the physical place where
we're going to bring the stuff.
But this is the
premise on which we're
basing this entire approach.
And I had to go and add this
slide just this morning.
A tech journalist, Ben Kepes
who I've long enjoyed his
takes on technology,
he tweeted this out.
Just saying that he sees this
particular announcement, GKE
On-Prem, as perhaps the
biggest announcement this week.
And this made me
very proud, in part
because of how much I
respect Ben's insights
into the industry.
But just how simply and
eloquently he said this.
And the fact that
that's exactly the point
that I hope to make-- one of
the points I hope to make here.
So GKE On-Prem-- first of
all, hopefully the name
describes it all.
It's Google's Kubernetes engine.
We've taken Kubernetes,
open-source Kubernetes.
We've built it in
the opinionated way
that we, Google, want to
run Kubernetes and host that
for our customers, for our
users of Google Cloud who want
a curated hosted experience.
Now that's not the only way
you can use and run Kubernetes.
There's lots of ways you
can use and run Kubernetes.
There's over 100
distributions of Kubernetes.
You can take it and
build it yourself.
I have.
It's fun.
But sometimes you
want someone else
to worry about managing
that, running that data
center, that hardware, those
VMs, securing the entire stack,
providing the updates, the
security, the maintenance
over time.
And that's what GKE is, Google's
hosted Kubernetes engine.
And of course our competitors
have their own offerings.
What we're doing here
is, we're literally
taking the same bits, the
exact same bits that we use,
and we run inside
of Google's data
centers to provide GKE
Google's hosted version.
But we're going to do that
on prem in a data center
wherever it is that
you want to run GKE.
The asterisk here is
part of the safe harbor.
I'm required to tell you this
is now an early access program.
And I have a URL for
you at the very end
where you can go
and sign up to have
early access to this
technology and these features,
this extension of
Google Cloud itself.
Now what is it?
Fundamentally this is, I
think, all in one slide
this is just about it all.
It's a single pane of
glass that gives you
real visibility, administrative
visibility, monitoring
and logging visibility,
across workloads
running in Google Cloud--
GCP, Google Cloud Platform--
as well as on prem
in your data center.
You're able to
orchestrate and manage
those workloads, those
containers, just the same
whether it's on prem
or in the Cloud.
The operating
model is consistent
and I think that's important.
It's really important.
There's a lot of
variability in the way
that Kubernetes is used.
And there are some
ways that are maybe
attractive from one
perspective or another.
What we've done, we think,
is we've put a lot of effort
into the UI and the UX,
the user experience,
for how container orchestration
should look inside
of Google Cloud.
And now that's available
on prem as well.
But the operations is really
at the heart of it, right?
Google's site reliability
engineers, SREs,
are absolutely
world class when it
comes to taking care of your
technology inside of our data
centers.
But now we're using
those same tools
to install and configure and
automate and update, maintain,
and deploy that on prem the same
way we do that in Google Cloud.
The environments are consistent.
And consistency
is super important
when you're programming
against APIs.
Knowing that those
APIs are going
to be the same in one
place as well as another.
That those operating
system images
are available both hosted
in the Cloud and on prem,
updated, maintained, secured.
And that the same components
are available in one
place and another.
Now, the Google Cloud
is quite rich in terms
of how many different features
and plug-ins there are
and how tightly
those are coupled.
And over time we're
working to bring as many
of those as possible
on prem as well.
We're starting with
Kubernetes itself,
the core orchestration
of containers itself.
And then you can
imagine the other things
that might make sense to
run alongside that inside
of your data center.
But we go beyond that.
So there's automated
operations, but there's also
management and help with that.
And so we're offering full and
partially managed Kubernetes.
Where the real magic is,
is in the automation,
in the intelligence that we've
built over time as to what
it takes to keep a
node up and healthy,
running, predictive
when that node is not
going to be healthy at
some point in the future
so that we can take
corrective action.
One of the most beautiful
things about Kubernetes
from a technology standpoint
is that it was designed
with this in mind, right?
I've been around Linux
and open source software
for a couple of decades
and the number of projects
that add this sort
of health monitoring
after the fact, that's
almost the de facto standard.
Kubernetes is sort of
the exception in that it
was built so that updates
and upgrades could
happen with zero downtime.
It's quite an elegant
concept but it's
really simple at its core.
Whenever we want
to upgrade a node,
we take that node out of
the pool of eligible nodes
for workloads to be scheduled
to it so that no new workloads
show up on that node.
We then drain that node of those
workloads, move them elsewhere.
Then we can take that node
offline, do an upgrade.
And then in some cases
we just, we kill the node
and we start a new node.
All of that's built directly
into Kubernetes itself
and has been from day one.
So from Cluster
Health, Auto Repair,
these are services that
Google provides to GKE
and we're bringing to
you GKE On-Prem as well.
OK, so that's the first
section of the talk.
As the biggest
announcement, I think,
here this week GKE On-Prem
is an absolute game
changer for enterprise IT.
The second section of this talk
is really the customer empathy
section of the talk.
Here, I think we've done
a lot of work and research
to understand why
hybrid cloud actually
is important to the enterprise
CIO, to the IT department,
to the director of a data center
who has real needs-- real needs
to run some workloads
on prem and just can't
run those in the cloud.
And so I've got roughly
10 use cases, use cases
that we've learned,
we've studied,
for why and when and where
hybrid cloud actually
makes sense.
And those 10 separate
use cases sort of
fit into one of
these six buckets.
I know I said 10, this is six.
We have six buckets and each
of the next 10 sort of apply.
So for these next 10 slides,
I'd like just a little bit
of audience participation.
I'm going to show 10
different places where
we think hybrid cloud actually
matters and makes sense and is
a requirement in some cases.
So if one any one of
these next 10 slides--
and you can vote
multiple times--
actually sings to you,
speaks to your heart,
just give me a thumbs up.
And that will help
us, especially some
of the other product managers
who are here in the audience,
help us just
understand the impact
that some of these
approaches actually
have in your businesses.
All right, so here we go.
So let's just try this.
Thumbs up?
All right, all right.
That's all we have to do.
Simple, right?
You don't have to stand up.
You don't have to say anything.
Just a simple thumbs up.
OK, so one example of
a hybrid environment
that I've got personal
experience with
is working in the banking
and fin tech industry
where some workloads
have to run next
to a stock exchange, period.
It just, laws of
physics, the wiring,
the copper between the fiber
between the data center
and the stock exchange,
the length of that matters.
And a matter of a
few hundred meters
makes a difference from
a latency perspective.
There are workload,
some workloads,
that need these
nanosecond latencies.
This is very much event
driven processing.
Something happens, and then
something else needs to happen.
It needs to happen
very close to where
that first event happened.
And it's real money.
There's real money involved
when those latencies go
beyond a certain tolerance.
There are in many cases very
specialized hardware involved,
hardware that's not available
in the public cloud.
Some of this hardware
is custom designed
ASICs or very particular
field programmable hardware.
And highly
proprietary algorithms
that, for better or worse,
for one reason or another,
just will not move outside
of an on prem environment.
Now, all of that said,
there are complements
to that on-prem workload that
make a lot of sense in a Google
Cloud.
There are jobs that run
nightly as a batch job.
In many cases we're
talking about models
that can be trained, and
are trained, and improve--
incrementally improve--
every single night,
but harness the
public cloud to do so.
Those are not time
sensitive just as long
as it takes place once a night
or once a week or once a month
and integrates all of
the transactions that
have happened in the previous
day or week or month.
And that model
improves over time.
And that can be run at
a much lower expense,
or perhaps more efficiently,
in the public cloud,
in Google Cloud.
In many cases, those algorithms
are developed and tested
in the public cloud.
But they end up running
locally next to the stock
exchange, or stock exchanges.
And then from an event
driven standpoint,
Cloud Pub/Sub is an
excellent Google technology
that allows you to create
publications and subscriptions
and take certain actions
when this happens.
All right, to anyone in
the room, does this one--
a few thumbs up.
OK, good.
So let's go from the
suits and pinstripes
to maybe what these
stockbrokers are
doing at night, which is
playing Counter Strike at home
at night.
So multiplayer online gaming--
increasingly so, and I've worked
with a number of companies
that deal with massive
multiplayer online gaming--
increasingly so,
the online games
where you're interfacing with
another player, your avatar
that you see on your
phone or on your screen,
is actually a container
running somewhere in the world.
And the people that
you're interacting with,
that you're collaborating
with to build a city or you're
shooting up because, you
know, they're the bad guys
and you're the
good guys, they're
actually a container
running, ideally,
in the same data
center and perhaps even
on the same physical machine.
And it ends up being a container
shooting at another container
where those things are
all happening inside
of a data center.
And it's happening like this.
[SNAPPING FINGERS] And all
you're seeing, ultimately
on your screen, is a physical
rendering of what happens.
And that's becoming
more and more
the standard as we play
games on little bitty devices
like this that have
very minuscule CPU
and GPU to handle all
of that processing.
And you're basically
watching a YouTube
video of yourself playing a
game, is what it ends up being.
And all of that happens
inside of a data center.
Now, sometimes those
happen in public clouds.
And Google's got
an excellent set
of customers running gaming
hosts inside of Google Cloud.
But in some cases, those
require on prem resources.
I've seen a few that
need bare metal--
no virtualization, bare metal.
That tends to be
a requirement when
latencies are
extremely low and there
is no concern for
multi-tenancy, right?
And ultimately
these are apps that
are containerized
and running inside
of what amounts to a Kubernetes
or some sort of container
scheduling algorithm.
Now, what happens
in the public cloud?
What happens in Google Cloud?
Well, often there is a
global control plane.
There's consolidated
identity and billing.
That's the first point of
entry to either the web
interface or the app interface.
And then traffic gets directed
to separate geo located,
perhaps, environments.
So from stock exchange to
multiplayer online gaming.
Does anyone have a
business need around this?
Or is this just like fun?
OK, cool, bit of both, great.
So, a third case is the
telco base station, OK?
I've spent a lot of
time working with telco,
and I've had the privilege
to actually visit
a couple of telco base stations.
Has anyone ever been inside
of a telco base station,
underneath the cell tower?
There, all right, good.
You can tell us what it's like.
But the ones that I've seen,
especially the new ones
that are being built to
handle 5G connectivity,
involve multiple
racks of servers.
Typically they're
caged off in such a way
that Sprint has one cage,
and Verizon has another cage,
and AT&T has a third cage.
And inside of each
of those cages
there's a rack of hardware.
In a small cell tower
it's a half rack.
In some of the big ones
it's multiple racks
of real, physical
servers cranking
the data that's going to your
phone and from your phone.
And these are local
applications that
run inside of each cell tower.
There are content distribution
networks, caching of data.
You know, we're watching
more videos on our phones.
And I certainly enjoy
watching the World Cup.
I did a lot of
that from my phone.
Much of that data was being
cached at the local cell
tower, when you're watching
that over a 4G connection
for instance.
And these are largely
third party applications,
not developed by the telco,
applications that they
buy to handle the
routing of SMS messages
and the playing of
content and simple stuff
like making phone calls, right?
And there is a massive
amount of computing power
necessary to do that.
And it has to be done
at the cell tower.
It has to happen
Now what's really
interesting about this
is that this is a case
where there's typically
lots of computing power and
a huge pipe of data flowing
from that cell tower back to
the data center or to the cloud.
And so this is
definitely a case where
we've seen the vendors in
this space wanting Kubernetes,
or something like
Kubernetes, to handle
the orchestration of those
many and varied apps, apps that
are being developed and
released and patched
and updated at cycles that
are asynchronous with the rest
of the development cycles, and
certainly with one another,
right?
You've got vendors
in that cell tower
from lots of
different companies.
Now, what happens
inside of Google Cloud
could be the control
plane, again.
Certainly the handling of the
remote management and updates.
When you've got
tens of thousands
of these cell towers
rolling out updates,
it requires a very centralized
management control plane.
And then consolidating
the logging and analytics,
being able to audit those,
search those, detect failures,
train models on when some
hardware is about to fail
and you have to roll a truck out
there to replace some hardware.
All right, so telco
industry-- anyone?
Has anyone seen this?
Yeah, exactly.
This need for hybrid computing.
So video transcoding.
These are in no
particular order,
but video transcoding
is a little bit
related to that
multiplayer online gaming
situation in that it's in
the media and entertainment
industry.
But we've seen a ton of video
transcoding algorithms being
implemented on
top of Kubernetes.
It's a perfect platform
for dividing up
massive jobs of transcoding.
Typically, what
happens when some video
needs to be produced
and delivered
to all of our devices--
you know, we've got many
and varied devices just here
in this room from our
phones to our laptops
to iPads or tablets.
Each of those has a
different resolution.
And in many cases, the
video is transcode it
for literally every
different resolution
that it might need to
be transmit to just so
that it can be done as
efficiently and optimized
as well as possible for
your particular environment.
Now, there's the fun and
exciting things like movies
in 3D and 4K and
working with some
of the interesting video
production houses in Hollywood.
And then there's the really
boring stuff, which is actually
most of the video in the world.
And it's the
security cameras that
are around every public place,
every shopping mall, hotel.
Much of that video transcoding
takes place first on prem.
And then some of it is
archived to the cloud.
Samples of it gets
archived to the cloud
or there's cold storage
being stored in the cloud.
But it often takes a
local transcoding job
to handle the massive
amount of data.
So again, this is
just laws of physics.
The data can't transfer fast
enough to the public cloud.
Some of that needs to be
done in local and on prem.
But once it gets
to Google Cloud,
some of the vision ML APIs
that are being developed inside
of Google Cloud are
absolutely amazing.
If you've used
Google Photos, I've
been blown away by going
through 20 years of photos
that I've uploaded
to Google Photos.
And I was looking for this
picture of a watermelon
that in college we
blew up because it's
fun to blow up things when
you're in college in Texas.
And so we blew up a watermelon.
And we were laughing about
this, me and some buddies,
at our union some time ago.
And I just wondered,
can I find that picture?
And sure enough, I
typed in watermelon.
I found about two dozen
watermelon pictures
over the years.
And it was amazing.
One was like a dress
my daughter was
wearing with little
watermelon cartoons on it.
And Google Photos figured
out that was a watermelon.
And sure enough, we found
the watermelon we blew up.
And that was a fun time.
But the fact that once you
get that data into the cloud
and you can run those
algorithms, video transcoding
is extremely powerful
when coupling on prem
with public cloud.
So video transcoding, has
anyone had video transcoding
jobs that they've
needed to run on prem?
Yeah.
So, retail-- I think I've met
more retail customers this week
than maybe ever in my career.
And I've dealt with
some big retailers.
But this particular
week has been
an extremely enlightening
and interesting set
of conversations around
retail computing.
And the retail industry, as
much as we buy things online
and they get delivered
to our house,
there still is this massive,
massive brick and mortar
retail industry.
And it's not going anywhere.
And in fact, that
retail industry
is investing heavily in clusters
of servers and computers
there, on prem, inside
of a shopping center.
Almost every shopping
center, whether it
be a mall or a strip mall
or just a set of stores,
shares a little bit of
compute typically provided
by the landlord or the owner
of that retail who usually owns
a few of those and has a very
similar software and hardware
setup spread across
those different things.
And whether it's a
giant big box retailer
or it's a small chain
of stores, there's
consistency in the hardware and
software that gets rolled out.
So there's typically, whether
you realize it or not, there's
typically a cluster of servers
in the back of the shopping
center that handles a
bunch of local apps.
And we've already talked
about video transcoding.
But there's about a
dozen cameras per--
what is the number?
Per 1,000 square feet
to cover that much area.
And there's a reel of
tape-- and it's not
tape-- a reel of hard drives
storing those recordings
locally so that when
there is a problem
and they need to give off that
data to local law enforcement,
they can do so.
And that's all local.
That hasn't been transferred.
And then there's cold storage
that happens in the cloud
and in archive.
And then there's
inventory management.
Some building automation,
the HVAC or the lighting,
being able to handle
and control that.
In some cases, there are city
regulations that some of that
needs to happen and be
able to happen locally
in the case of an
emergency and has
to have a fallback
plan when it can't
connect to an internet
connected service.
And of course, the
point of sale system.
The heart of every business
is a point of sale system.
Typically your credit
card transactions
are logged locally.
They're batch sent to
the payment processor.
But there's a backup kept
for some amount of time
just in case something happens.
You've probably seen that
credit card transaction
that didn't show up for a
few weeks or a month or two,
but then showed back up.
And it was because someone
had to go back in and check
an audit log, found
something missing,
and was able to pull that off
of a second copy or a local copy
perhaps.
Now all that said, Google
Cloud offers a real compliment
to this retail cluster, whether
that's a global web presence,
being able to direct that
traffic geographically
to the best possible
location or server,
certainly cloud storage for the
video and those transactions,
the AutoML, and the insights,
the buying patterns,
the user buying patterns.
There's been a number of
good sessions this week
about the retail industry.
So retail, sorry.
Anyone here from-- or, sorry,
let me not ask anyone here
from retail.
Does this use case speak
to some of your needs?
Yep.
Smart buildings and
smart cities-- you know,
one of the biggest places I
think we will see in this next
decade a real market improvement
in our life is through
automation, safety,
improvements--
technology driven
improvements-- in the way
we live and interact
with one another.
And that can be in both rural
environments as well as highly
dense environments like this.
And this really starts
with smart buildings
and smart cities.
So just about everything that
I said about a retail shopping
center that has a rack of
servers doing things that
have to be done locally, as
well as most of what I said
about a telco base station with
some applications that need
to run locally, if you go
to any of these high rise
modern skyscrapers
there's a rack
of servers in the basement
doing building automation
and certain transactions
that have to happen
within that building itself.
And I've said security I
don't know how many times now,
but it ends up being quite a
bit of security feeds, HVAC,
and just running the operations
of the building itself.
Now the smart part of smart
buildings and smart cities
is using AI and ML to
train models and improve
the performance and operation
of some of those aspects
that we come to depend on from
a technology and infrastructure
perspective.
Training those in the cloud and
sending the models, the trained
models, back down to the
clusters to implement
is really an
interesting handshake.
So smart buildings,
smart cities, this one
might be a little
bit on the fringe.
But does anyone have any
experience in this space
and see hybrid computing?
Yeah, that's good.
So data provenance is one
that I think we've all
experienced this year.
Anyone who's had anything
to do with GDPR, and then
prior to GDPR or any of
the other personal privacy
protection--
either legislation
or regulations
and in some cases
just our own processes
that we have in the enterprise
around where data can be,
how long it can
live, how it needs
to be encrypted and treated.
And in some cases there are
simply legal obligations,
there are compliance
requirements,
around where that data lives.
And no matter how secure
and encrypted at all levels
Google Cloud actually is,
there are some processes
that just require some data to
be stored locally and on prem.
And we will continue
to improve the security
and the compliances and
the list of compliances--
it's actually quite an
impressive list at this link
here--
of compliance audits that
Google Cloud has passed.
We'll continue growing that.
But there is some data that
for one reason or another,
it needs to live somewhere else.
And perhaps it's
inside of a country.
In some cases it may just be
for a liability limitation.
There's an insurance
policy that a company might
have where their insurance
policy is different depending
on where their data
is stored, or that's
what their auditors
have told them.
Now that said, inside
of Google Cloud
we do have a really rich
security feature set.
Your data is encrypted at every
single level all the way down
the stack of virtual machines.
You're booting in Trusted
Boot environments.
And then there are extremely
fine grained identity
and access controls.
Our back access controls around
that you have control of as to
in your organization who can
access given buckets of data.
So from that
perspective, this is
a case where some data
lives in some places
and some data is
replicated elsewhere.
Some data is encrypted
with a set of keys
that stores the data, but it's
protected unless those keys are
available.
So from a data
provenance perspective,
this is another driver
for some hybrid use cases.
Does this resonate with anyone?
Wow, that's a
popular one for sure.
So then we go toward
lift and shift.
Lift and shift being maybe
some traditional workloads
that have long lived in
an enterprise data center,
but for one reason
or another you'd
like to move them to
the cloud, possibly even
in the other direction in that
it can really go either way.
I've seen, and I've worked with,
a couple of large customers
moving virtual
machines to the cloud.
Google acquired a company
called Velostrata.
And I'm the product manager
associated with Velostrata
as we're working to integrate
Velostrata a bit tighter
into Google Cloud.
But Velostrata has
some technology
that will take a VMware
virtual machine image
and live stream that
image to Google Compute
Engine without
downtime and actually
move that VMware image into
a VM in the public cloud,
in Google's cloud.
And it's really
quite impressive.
It's a great demo.
And it's something that we've
helped organizations move
thousands of legacy
applications running
in VMware inside of
their data center
into a hosted cloud environment.
I've certainly been in a data
center with old dusty machines
that no one's quite
sure how it's still
working because,
you know, the fan
makes a noise about
60 times a second.
And at any point
it could fall over.
And boy, that's just
going to be a bad day.
And so moving some of those
workloads into the cloud
tends to be a priority.
And in some cases, this
is what people really
mean when they
mean hybrid cloud,
being able to just move a
good old VM from one place
to another.
And we're seeing more and
more of that with Kubernetes.
As these applications
are lifted and shifted
they're actually
moved and improved.
They're modernized as they
actually move into a cloud.
And there are some advantages
to be had by moving them
into a container.
Not having to worry about
kernel updates, for instance.
And that the real point is that
most legacy software actually
predates the cloud.
That's sort of the definition of
legacy at this juncture in time
anyway.
And from that perspective,
some of those workloads
can't or won't or
just are not well
suited to moving
to the Google Cloud
for one reason or another.
And that might be impetus
for, in some cases,
using both on prem for some
workloads and public cloud
for other workloads.
So from a lift and
shift perspective,
is this an initiative with
within anyone's organization?
Yeah, we see that quite a bit.
So this is a fun one.
And I actually know of a
really interesting young man.
He's interned for me a
couple of different times.
But in his last internship he
had this really interesting
job, which was to create a
calculator that would determine
for a given job--
he was working
for a company that
did a lot of large,
large scale AI ML job,
jobs that cost tens of
thousands of dollars
to run just one time.
Just running this job one
time it was tens of thousands
of dollars.
And his job as an intern was
to figure out the cheapest way
to run that job,
meaning which cloud,
whether to use GPUs or TPUs,
how big the instances should be.
And that tool saved
this company maybe 20%,
maybe $2,000,
$3,000, for each job
if it could find the
cheapest right way to run it.
Now their organization
was entirely public cloud,
but I've seen this
model actually
work where sometimes
it makes more sense
to simply run a job on prem
for one reason or another.
In other cases it makes
more economic sense
to run that in Google
Cloud, for instance.
And so you get this sort
of decision tree of when
to do which and it's
actually quite simple--
wherever it's
cheaper, wherever it's
less expensive or costs less.
And I call that the
economic arbitrage.
It's like we're going
to arbitrage this job
and run it where
it's most efficient.
Does anyone have to
make this decision,
or has an algorithm to make
this decision for them?
Yeah.
It's a real driver for business.
And you know, it can show
you where your efficiencies
are available.
So this is kind of the classic
dev test CI CD into prod.
I've worked with
organizations that
do all of their development
in the public cloud
but then run their
production servers on prem.
And I've seen
exactly the opposite.
We do all of our development
on our laptops, on our Macs,
on our Linux machines.
But then we run and host
our production servers
in the cloud.
And so, you know what?
We're not prescriptive about
that from this perspective.
I'm certainly not
prescriptive about it.
Whatever makes sense.
Bringing GKE on
prem, for instance,
gives you the
ability to do either.
You can use the on prem
cluster for your dev and test
and GKE for production.
I certainly think that
makes a lot of sense.
But you could just as easily
do it in the other direction
and send your load balancers
and your traffic elsewhere.
And so I think this is one
of the classic hybrid models,
using a bit of public
cloud, a bit of on prem.
I'm guessing a few
people have experience
with doing this for sure.
Yeah.
And then finally,
the last one is--
and I've seen this
now from a number
of banks in some regulated
industries that are
deemed just too big to fail--
that they're actually
spreading workloads
across multiple clouds,
where running a Google Cloud
is great.
And then having
another plan actually
is required by industry
regulations just in case.
And so there's a lot of
reasons that could go here.
But I think this is a
different type of hybrid cloud.
This one isn't necessarily
on prem to Google Cloud.
It certainly can be.
But it could be from other
clouds to Google Cloud.
So does this one hit
home with anyone?
Yeah.
OK, so that's our 10 use cases.
I've studied each of these.
And we've put together,
from a product and strategy
team, put together quite
a number of critical user
journeys through each of these.
And we are working from
a hybrid cloud computing
standpoint with these in mind.
So maybe at the end
I'll ask if there's--
I'll just ask right now.
I've got just a
couple of minutes.
Is there any major use
case that I've missed here?
Or do these pretty
much cover it?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Research Institute?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
GPU hardware, yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
that's a great example.
They've got a lot of
hardware that they've
invested in, GPU hardware
in a research institute.
And it's sort of
there and you want
to use it because it's there.
But you want to take advantage
of newer GPUs, perhaps newer
hardware, and the
burstability of public cloud.
Good, thank you.
OK, so the third
point to make here
is that we really do
have a world class cloud.
I hope that you've
enjoyed your week here.
I think we're
starting to wrap up.
I found this an amazing
three day exhibition
of just innovation
and inspiration
of how much work my
colleagues, my engineers,
put into what they do every day.
I've learned about
corners of Google
that I didn't know existed.
Some of the announcements
were new to me as to you here.
Hopefully, you've been
educated a little bit.
But I think hopefully the
previous section shows you
that we really
know, we've really
come to understand-- we're
coming to understand what
hybrid cloud is by
classifying this,
understanding these use cases,
having this sort of feedback.
But I think that the inverse
is actually true as well.
I think hybrid actually knows
Google, and actually uses
Google, in a lot
of different ways.
If we start with the last 10,
15 years of Google products,
Enterprise products,
it goes from G Suite,
from using Google Docs
and maybe Hangouts
or Mail calendaring
inside of the enterprise,
while the enterprise still
has its own IT data center.
This is a piece of
IT that used to be
in servers stored locally,
storage maybe for documents.
Who remembers emailing
documents around?
Boy what a miserable time it
was to work in this industry
when everybody would get a
copy, their own copy, of a doc.
And I mean, how did you
do collaborative editing?
I couldn't live
without that today.
It's like going back
to a typewriter.
The leap is almost the same.
But now that's all
stored essentially
in Google's public cloud,
but secured and cordoned off.
To Android Enterprise,
being able to use
those same apps
securely on a phone,
managed by an IT
security organization--
your own IT security
organization who does that
through Google's technology.
And then it's really coming
to Google Cloud, as well.
The enterprise using,
leveraging, Google Cloud.
And I'm here to really just
talk about Kubernetes engine.
But there's so many of these
products that are actually
quite applicable to the
enterprise and bridge that gap.
And that's the point here.
We're working hard to bridge
the gap between your data center
and Google's services.
And I say services
and not servers
because we really are looking
at this from a services
perspective.
We produce services that
you can consume APIs
that you can talk
to, applications
but those applications end up
being Google services in fact.
And GKE On-Prem is
super special here.
This is really the
first time we're
bringing Google's software into
the enterprise data center.
The only other
example we can really
think of here where Google's
done something similar
is the Search Appliance,
which was actually
a physical hardware appliance
that you installed in your rack
and indexed your data,
documents, websites,
on your internal internet.
That was a physical appliance.
This is different.
This is software,
Google software,
that runs inside of your
enterprise data center.
And that's a game changer.
That's really different.
I can't understate how important
that change actually is.
And so, wrapping this all
up and bringing it together,
I think if you
were going to take
a picture of one slide
this is the one that I
think says it all here.
If you really treat Google
Cloud as an extension
of your own data center,
just imagine how powerful
your data center ends up being.
Its sort of the
analogy of your phone
that has access to the internet.
And suddenly this
tiny little thing
has access to basically
all of the information that
has ever been created in
the history of mankind.
And this is your
interface to it.
If your data center itself
is connected to Google Cloud
and using Google
Cloud technologies,
just imagine how powerful
that data center becomes.
I'm actually going to skip
this and go straight to a demo.
I think you guys would rather
see a demo then an architecture
slide.
Very briefly, this is
the sort of architecture.
I've whitewashed all the
customer names and the customer
code names off of this.
But this is essentially a retail
use case, a retail customer,
who's using a blend
of Google Cloud
Platform and their own
online enterprise data center
as well as some
technology slated
to run on prem, in
the store on site.
That's just one architecture
for one of those 10 use cases
that I described.
But Google's customer
engineering team and solutions
architects can create
this sort of a design
by interacting with the right
person in your IT organization
very smoothly.
OK, so let's see a demo.
So this was that
single pane of glass
which was a snapshot
of a web page.
You want to see this in action?
Yeah?
OK.
I can't do demos
with a jacket on.
It's just-- it's not right.
It's absolutely not right.
All right, so I'm going
to get rid of that.
All right, this is my
Google Cloud console.
I'll blow that up a little bit.
And I've got a cluster running
on the east coast somewhere.
And that's my one cluster.
In fact, this is
the cluster-- this
is half of the cluster that
was used in Tuesday morning's
keynote, the one where
we had the big reveal
that there is actually, this
is being served on stage.
Half of that cluster was
running in Google Cloud.
The other half was
running there on stage.
Now what I want to
do at this point
is register an external cluster.
And for this cluster, I'm going
to name this cluster Cluster
Palace.
And unfortunately I was not
able to get the rack of hardware
up here.
But I do happen
to have Kubernetes
running on my Linux laptop
right here in Palace Gold Room.
So I'm registering
this external cluster.
I'm going to download
this manifest.
And I'm now on my local cluster
and I can do a kubectl get all.
And you can see I've got
a little Kubernetes up
and running here on my laptop.
Now if I simply kubectl
apply to the name space,
GKE connect, the YAML
file that I just download,
that will set some
key value pairs.
And I'm going to see this is
waiting for that connection
to happen.
And while that's happening,
actually, let's go back
and do something else.
Let's register another cluster.
And this is going to be a
bare metal cluster that's
running in Texas.
So I'm going to
download that one.
And I'm going to come over to
my bare metal cluster in Texas
and I'm going to kubectl apply.
I'm going to just
make sure this is up.
OK, and I'm going to wait
for that one to come up.
And actually I need to
do one more little thing.
I need to enable a
couple of services.
And we're going to get to--
I'm going to need
to apply my secrets.
And I'll do that
there and that there.
And then we're going to
kick that off one more time.
All right, and what we
should see in just a minute
is a set of clusters
and workloads
that we can actually run
across each of these clusters.
So-- OK, so now
that one connected.
And I'm going to continue
to the configuration.
And I need to go and fetch
a secret, a token, here.
And I need to get this token.
Let me make sure I
got the right token.
So now I'm going to
configure this cluster.
And I need to move
to authenticate.
Actually, I need
the end point first.
So let me get the end point.
Got the end point.
I need to continue
to authenticate.
And I need the token,
which I've got here.
And I'm going to Finish.
And I can now see, my
laptop is registered.
Cluster size of one, four
CPUs, 16 total cores.
And I can now go over
to the Workloads tab.
And I can see my cluster,
Cluster Palace, is running.
And I have a GKE Connect agent.
Now I'm going to deploy the
workload locally using kubectl.
So now I'm on my development
cluster here on the laptop.
I'm going to deploy and
expose that workload.
And I can see that it's running.
And that's its IP
address, port 9876.
And so on I can go to here.
And I can see every
time I refresh this,
I get a cute little--
cute, look at that.
And adjective and an animal.
Now what's amazing is that
if I refresh my workloads
tab on this, I can see
the pet name Workload.
This is running in
Google Cloud and I've
got a workload here running.
OK, that's pretty amazing.
Now, probably the top
question that we've
gotten over the last
two days is, can I
run GKE On-Prem on bare metal?
Can I run GKE On-Prem
in Amazon, even
though it's called GKE On-Prem?
And so that question has come
up over and over and over again.
So what I'm about to show you
is certainly not a product plan.
But I'm about to show
you that the GKE Connect
technology, yes, it works just
the same across the board.
So I've got an instance
running here in Amazon.
And if I kubectl
get all, I can see
I've got some workloads
running here inside of here.
And if I go to my clusters and
I register an external cluster,
and I call this
the cluster AWS--
simply for demo purposes.
And I go over and I apply the
secrets.yaml and the cluster
AWS, connect.
And I come back here and voila.
We are now connected.
And if I continue to this
and I get my local endpoint--
it's important to
understand this.
There is a local endpoint.
This is not routable.
I have to have the
connection agent
to get to that local endpoint.
And I continue.
And I need to get the token.
Get-- and I've got this
token, kubectl describe.
And this token is
unique per cluster,
so I've got to copy that
each and every time.
And now I'm registered.
And it's going to take
a second for the cluster
size in the cores
to come up as it
starts exchanging information.
And we are actually out of time.
But hopefully we will get to
see some workloads populate here
in just a second.
OK, are we strictly
out of time or can
I take a question or two?
We're strictly out of time.
I cannot take a question or two.
All right, I will be
just outside the room
and I'm happy to talk to
anyone about more of this
if you'd like to see it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]